She was like, if we lived under Islamic
rule, there would be no Epstein falls.
That's because Epstein would be praised
as a prophet like your Muhammad. Perhaps
we wouldn't be going through the falls
because just like your our prophet
Muhammad.
This is the new Sadaqah Jariyah in town.
On the day of judgement, the first thing
we will be asked about is our prayer.
Now imagine being part of a project that
teaches thousands of people around the
world for just 100 pounds. You can help
teach 20 to 60 people.
>> Like me. Learn how to pray salah.
>> And when they teach their children and
their children's children.
The reward continues. Do not miss the
Sadaqah Jariyah. Donate today. And
[music] earn rewards that last beyond
your lifetime. Go to the link and donate
now.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh brothers and sisters in the
faith. I hope you guys are well. So I
came across this video
of this Christian
evangelizing lady. She was very
passionate talking in the name of Christ
etc. You know, there is no hatred like
Christian love. So let's see what she
has to say. So a she is sister a hijabi
sister put a
post out saying that there would be
if the world were governed by the
Islamic principles, the Epstein falls
wouldn't exist. And instead of this
lady, this white woman
coming and saying, you know what, that's
true.
That is true. Nope. Nope, they're going
to have to shift the blame. Let's watch
what she has to say and let's actually
annihilate her by her own book and her
scripture inshallah. Let's see what she
has to say.
She was like, if we lived under Islamic
rule, there would be no Epstein falls.
That's because Epstein would be praised
as a prophet like your Muhammad. Perhaps
we wouldn't be going through the falls
because just like your our prophet you
praised. Maybe you would have made him a
prophet as well. Muhammad was the
original Jeffrey Epstein. Them two would
have gotten along well. They were the
same KIND OF THING. YOU KNOW, marrying
Aisha at six and consummating at nine.
Did you know Let's let me get this
right. Okay. So your great if I'm not
mistaken 250,000 girls in America in
your country have been
married under age. Under age 12 250,000
quarter of a million. And only that, the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. Like
we said we've we've discussed this many
times. Okay, he married her when she
became an adult. Yes, we believe she was
an adult. She was an equivalent of a
16-year-old or even 15, 14-year-old,
16-year-old girl today. She was an adult
1,400 years ago. And there are many
studies to show girls maturing much
younger, the life expectancy, you name
it. So, not only that, the Prophet
Muhammad, peace be upon him, married
her. She was She was proposed to before
that. So, we've discussed this topic.
I'm not going to go into this hundreds
of times. Okay. So, you think Epstein,
this pedophilia issue is your issue.
Okay, your dad is most likely a most
likely look like a pedophile than anyone
else. White middle-aged men with all
Let's be Let's be honest here. The
majority of the culprits are these
individuals. You guys are sickos. And
let's carry on, Inshallah. Let's see
what else she has to say. Because if you
look at it, you are dealing with
individuals who are not only accused of
killing,
eating,
sexually abusing minors, minors,
kidnapping them. Your satanic cult.
Okay, this is coming from This is a
Western problem, not a Muslim problem.
So, nice try. Let's carry on. Let's see
what else she has to say.
>> being repulsed by someone like Jeffrey
Epstein, being repulsed
Did you know that that's not
self-evident? Do you think that humans
just have this INSTINCTUAL THING OF
KNOWING what is evil and what's
disgusting? No, it's not. It's not
self-evident. How do I know that?
Because it's not universal and it's not
timeless. There are still so many
countries in our time today that think
that child marriage
All this kind of abuse is totally moral.
Yeah, exactly, like your country. Yeah,
yeah, you're right, like your country.
So, she's saying it's not inherently
that we know good good or bad, etc. It
has to be from scripture. Yeah, we
believe that. But, let's see what else
she has to We believe the Quran is our
moral guidance for us. Next, see what
she has to say. tells me it's not an
instinct in humanity. We needed somebody
to tell us evil and what is right from
what is wrong. And it hasn't always been
this way throughout history. Before the
Bible came into the picture, we would
have all thought that Oh, okay. Okay, so
we need someone to tell us good and bad.
Okay, and where do we need to go to? We
need to go to the Bible. Okay, all
right. Let's Let's see. Okay, carry on.
Jeffrey Epstein WAS A NORMAL GUY. YOU
OUGHT to thank God that you live in a
Christian civilization. Because if you
are opposed by someone LIKE JEFFREY
EPSTEIN, THE ONLY REASON YOU ARE OPPOSED
by his wickedness is it's you were
raised up in a Christian nation THAT HAS
THE BIBLE AS A FOUNDATION FOR MORALITY.
OH, OKAY, INTERESTING. Let's go to the
Bible then. Um, I would like to I would
love to see you're saying the criteria
is what that we should go to scripture.
We believe this, that we should go to
scripture. The scripture tells us what's
good and bad. Objective morality comes
from God Almighty. We believe Quran is
from God Almighty. You have no evidence
the Bible is, but let's go with that
issue. Let's So, let's go to the Bible.
So, you're talking about morality. Okay,
that's good. I think universally
everyone would agree that a woman should
not be raped. Okay, so your argument was
what? We don't in instinctively and
intuitively we do not know good or bad.
We need to go to scripture. Scripture is
what? The Bible. Okay, interesting. So,
if we go to the Bible, we will say
universally everyone in the entire
global world will say raping a woman is
bad. It's wrong. It's morally
corrupt. It's disgusting. Okay.
And now you're saying, "No, no, no, no,
no. We don't know that. We need to go to
the Bible." We're like, "Okay. All
right. No problem. We are wrong. Okay.
Okay. Or the Bible is in line with us.
Okay. We believe all Go to any country
anywhere they will say raping a woman is
wrong." Let's see what the Bible has to
say. It's either going to say something
better or equivalent. Right. Go to the
book of Deuteronomy chapter 22 verse 29.
Then the man that lay with her shall
give her unto the damsel's father 50
shekels of silver, and he shall be his
wife because he have humbled her, he may
not put her away all his days.
Interesting. So, when if you as a
Christian woman get to raped, yes,
raped, and if you got raped, well, it's
very it's very simple. The matter is
very simple really resolved. Okay. Um,
that um, the man pays 50 shekels to your
father and you become his wife. You
become the rapist's wife. Hm,
interesting. So, we talked about going
back to scripture. If you go to back
scripture, which is Quran, this happened
at the time of the prophet Muhammad,
peace be upon him, in a hadith that a
woman was raped and she uh shouted and
the man, the culprit, would actually
they caught the wrong person and he was
about to be executed till the actual
culprit came and said, "No, it was me."
And they gave him the capital
punishment. Well, there's no capital
punishment here. You just give 50
shekels. It's all right. It's like
buying Amazon Prime. You just give the
50 shekels, whatever it is, and she is
your wife. So,
Christian men could just go around just
raping and just saying, "I've got I'm so
sorry. I just had a temptation. I raped
her. Here's your 50 shekels. She is my
wife now. It's It's as simple as that.
Not even In Islam, you can't even you
need to ask the permission of a woman.
The woman doesn't even take your surname
because she's not your property. Dude,
the woman has a right to divorce. Okay,
so is this in scripture? No, it's not.
When we go to Book of Numbers chapter 31
and verse 18, what do we see? Let's see
what Jesus, the God of the Old
Testament. Let's go to scripture. What
does scripture say? But there is Yeah,
now therefore kill This is a This is
direction from Jesus telling them all
this. Now therefore kill every male Kill
every male among the little ones and
kill every woman that have known by man
living laying with them. But all the
woman children the all the woman
children woman children What the hell is
a woman children? All the girls
children. Yes? Okay, that have not known
a man meaning she's a virgin but let me
keep her alive for yourselves. And do
you abide with the camp seven days
whoever have killed any person. So you
can see keep the little girls for
yourself. Why are you going to play
Monopoly? Are you going to play game
with them? I wonder why. What happened
to morality? Do we go to the morality?
all agree that you should not go and
kill innocent men women children. The
Quran teaches that. Islam teaches that.
Your book says that you should kill
women who are not virgins and keep the
virgin ones for yourself. For what?
Yeah, Epstein files, right? Yeah, okay.
Not only that in the in First First
Samuel chapter 15 verse 2 to 3, if you
read it, again your Jesus that's very
moral go to the Amalekites and kill men,
women, children, babies, donkey. Now
interestingly when we go to the Quran,
there is not a single statement that you
can I've given three just examples.
There's many. Three examples. Nowhere in
Islam does it tell you to go to a land
and if Muslims went to war and you kill
women that are not virgins. Nowhere. In
Islam you're not allowed to kill
innocent men women children or babies.
Period. Okay, not pick the women who are
not virgins and keep the ones That's
That's impermissible in Islam. So our
scripture seems much more moral than
yours. And not only that, ethics of war.
Go and kill men, women, children,
babies, donkeys, every living thing.
Not a single place in the Quran or
Hadith or Islamic literature tells us
that when you go to war, you should
annihilate everyone.
This is your morality? This is
instinctive intuition you know everybody
knows we need to go to scriptures to not
find out. That woman Hijabi sister, she
said exactly right. If the Sharia
existed, Epstein files and all of those
Trump and whoever's at the top will be
hanged. They'll be executed. They'll be
crucified.
Yes, crucified. Not someone like if any
people people send innocent person, they
will be crucified. And we go to the
Quran and we don't find any of these
abhorrent things in Islam. So,
therefore, it proves us to us what? That
this issue of pedophilia is your
problem. You guys are disgusting people.
Okay, these disgusting individuals and
I'm not talking to this specific
individual. This is your problem. You
are disgusting. You think that you
behave like that. This is your problem
and every accusation is a confession.
And nowhere in Islam Islam deals with
this matter. We don't solve for them in
prisons and give them hot water, hot
bed, hot shower, hot food. Everything's
hot. Alhamdulillah, no. We don't pay
taxpayers money. We put them in the
public and execute them. So, any other
pedophile tries to do the same thing
they say, "Look, you see what happened
to that guy? He lost a left arm and a
right leg and he was crucified and he
bled to death." Yes, it might look
gruesome, but in Islam we believe
prevention is better than cure and mercy
on the oppressor it is oppression on the
innocent. And that's what we believe in
Islam and that is it. And you've got
absolutely scored. Go read your Bible.
Yes, the Jesus of the Old Testament
smash babies against rocks. Are you out
of your mind? There is nothing like that
in Islam and alhamdulillah Islam is from
God Almighty. It is preserved. It hasn't
been changed and it is morally in check
with our fitra in its position. That's
all I want to say inshallah and please
educate yourself. As a Christian woman,
you should be ashamed of yourself. Yes,
what happened to love your enemies?
Anyways, that's what I'm going to say
and that's all I've got to say. Nothing
else to say inshallah. Ramadan Mubarak.
May Allah bless you brothers and
sisters. Till next time. Assalamualaikum
Warahmatullahi Wabarakatuh. This is the
new sadaqah jariyah in town. On the day
of judgement, the first thing we will be
asked about is our prayer. Now, imagine
being part of a project that teaches
thousands of people around the world.
For just £100, you can help teach 20 to
60 people like me learn how to pray
salah. And when they teach their
children and their children's children
the reward continues. Do not [music]
miss the sadaqah jariyah. Donate today
and earn rewards that last beyond your
lifetime. Go to the link and donate now.